What do I do with my hands?
Hi!
My dad is the best dad because he is loving and caring.
Dad's hugs are the best hugs.
He's cool!
The best friend you'll ever have in your life.
Comforts us when we're sad and it feels good.
Dad's really strong.
He makes me believe in myself.
Makes me happy!
He crashes into walls all the time.
He makes funny fart sounds.
Dad is pretty weird.
If my Dad was a superhero, he would be Superman.
Superman!
The Daddynator!
Green Lantern.
Spidey.
If my dad had a super power, it would be rock climbing.
He could be flying.
He's already super strong so, I don't know.
He taught me how to be polite and do good manners.
He taught me how to ride my dirt bike.
He's taught me to never give up.
That I'm a princess, I'm special.
He taught me that I have a super power in the world.
I have a special gift that God has given me that not many people else have.
Don't pee in houses.
I love you Daddy!
You are awesome.
I really like it when you spend time with me.
You are the number one dad in the world.
You're the best dad in the world.
You're super.
I love you very very much, more than the whole world.
Happy Father's Day.
I love you.
Bye, Daddy.